M it's
God it's
God okay yeah so so Isaiah 53 um we're
talks about the one who's pierced for
our transgressions bruised for our
iniquities the Lord lays on him the sins
of us all if you were to apply that to
someone who does that sound like to you
I
mean off the bat it sounds like Jesus
but I mean the way that I interpret it
it interpret it as um is
um uh I view it as like someone who will
come or iew I view it more as like every
man I feel like every person kind of
goes through that process of of grief
and of um being tormented and uh that's
where they find God is in their deepest
uh is in their darkest times so now
what's interesting about this it's that
it's not as broad cuz it has like very
specific applications like the lord has
laid on him the sins of us all so he's
actually distinguished from the general
pop population you know yeah yeah so
with with the Lord putting sins on him
and him suffering and taking the
punishment for the people that's it's an
individual yeah I think it could be an
individual but I mean you know I
definitely think that you can interpret
it as Jesus and that's a very valid
interpretation I person like as a Jewish
person interpret it as if it is the
Messiah you know the mes the Messiah to
come um not that Jesus wasn't a
righteous person but you know I just
don't believe that he was the Messiah uh
and you know you could also view it as
like job cuz job was also like given a
lot of uh yeah but he didn't take the
sins of the people that is true that is
true that's that that's it's like like I
said because I hear what you're saying
like people G through struggles people
have their turbulence but this
specifically is saying his turbulence is
for others not his own you know and it's
the sins of people that he's taking on
like he's given up as an offering so I
personally just view it as you know I I
still kind of view it as like it could
be you know I think that a lot of people
just in general take a lot of things for
other people and um we kind of take ADV
or kind of taken advantage of and I
think that's kind of a part of being
human and I think one of the ways that
we can find like peace through that is
through God so I still personally view
it as that but I think that's a about
interpretation I appreciate it so let me
ask you this with this last thing okay
cuz you said you know you got to God I
want to hold you so just last question
with um with with you being able like
you know like you can acknowled like
yeah that's a valid interpretation if
it's you know that that's the case like
because it's a Messianic passage that
and Jesus fits that yeah why not accept
him as the Messiah if he fits the
prophecy um he didn't uh from like the
Jewish readings uh he didn't fulfill the
prophecy cuz the prophecy within Judaism
is that uh the Messiah comes when the
world ends he brings all the Jews back
to Israel and raises the dead raises all
of the Dead okay but when though when is
that when is that in the future got you
so the Messiah to come right so so so
here we have we have two things now
going so we have we have prophecies
where the Messiah will come and judge
and raise the dead right and Rule and
save people right and then we also have
the passage of is where the Messiah will
come in a humble way and and as a and
and suffer so we have two descriptions
of his coming so when it makees sense
that it there's maybe there's two times
that he comes the first time he suffers
the second time he comes to rule from my
understanding of Judaism it's only the
it's only when the when he raises the
dead and it's the end of the world could
it be could it be incorrect could that
be incorrect I don't view it as
incorrect but I mean you know it's your
opinion okay well yeah I'll take that
man I appreciate you uh
oh my God logic
[Music]